Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wollen wir nicht auch mal die Merkel interviewen?
Äh ich hätte ehrlich gesagt Sorge, dass die dann einen von uns streichelt.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer hundertachtundvierzig wieder in Standardbesetzung. Haben wir uns wieder zusammengefunden, Ninos, wie schön.
Ja, Tim, ist das nicht toll?
Ja, ist super. Aber.
Man dich auch mal, kann ich dich auch wenigstens mal streicheln bei der Gelegenheit.
Jetzt bitte nicht zu intim werden. Äh aber da muss man wirklich Angst vor haben. Es ähm.
Alter.
Das Ganze dann machen, wenn wir dann irgendwie live on stage sind äh Linus.
Wenn wir dann live on stage sind und Leute nicht reinlassen, ne? Stell dir mal vor, würden alle kommen.
Ja, nee, also so viel Platz ist ja auch nicht im Zelt dann, ne.
So viel Platz ist hier auch nicht.
Äh haben wir denn das überhaupt schon erwähnt? Das wir das vorhaben.
Aufm Camp zur Podcast hatten wir erwähnt, ja?
Hatten wir äh schon erwähnt, okay? Aber wir haben noch keine konkreten Uhrzeiten äh anzukündigen oder so.
Hast du eine konkrete Uhrzeit?
Ich könnte eine ankündigen, ich weiß bloß nicht, ob die ob die stimmt und auch schon ausreichend abgesprochen ist, ob man sich gegen irgendwelche äh planerischen äh Widerstände durchsetzen muss oder so. Das können wir ja dann noch äh in der nächsten Folge.
Und Widerstände, das ist halt Koordination, Koordination, das ist das reine Chaos in der in der Orga, ne, das uns jetzt auch gerade wieder zu Kopf steigt, Baumwoll.
Naja, auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall haben wir das vor und wir werden euch äh rechtzeitig noch ähm,
zur Kenntnis geben, wann denn das so genau sein wird, denn dann natürlich äh live und in Farbe mit Bild und Ton und Stream und äh allen Piper
was so dazu gehört heutzutage. Ja und sehr viel mehr können wir da glaube ich auch noch nicht zu sagen, weil so genau steht das auch alles noch nicht fest. Nichtsdesto.
Ich habe übrigens gestern meinen sorry, ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Ich habe gestern meinen Testaufbau gemacht fürs Camp.
Und er war gut.
Was empfinden? Was denn für ein Test auf?
Ja was man so aufbaut, ne? Man will da ja also beim Camp geht's ja auch, ne, sehen und gesehen werden. Das ist ja so die die Königsallee der des des internationalen Hackings.
Hm. Posen.
Will man natürlich auch ein ein vernünftigen, ja will man auch zeigen, ne? Wenn's was man hat.
Was man für Schlappen drauf hat.
Ja
Für den Auspuff äh.
Nee, nee, aber so, so ich habe mir dann.
Verkrumper Doppellüfter am Laptop. Ja.
Genau, ja, Wasser gekühlter Wasser gekühlter Club Mate, Behälter und so, ne?
Mhm, mhm.
Aber man will ja dann auch so seine seine Resistenz gegen die Widrigkeiten der Natur zeigen, ne. Habe jetzt zum Beispiel, als ich dann gelesen habe, ja, mit ähm Kühlschrank mitnehmen und so, ist nicht, da musste ich ja umdisponieren.
Keinen Kühlschrank mit dir nehmen, haben nicht genug Strom. Also habe ich eine Kühlbox gekauft, die mit Gas betrieben wird. Fuck you, Alter.
Das wollte ich eigentlich nicht verraten, weil äh jetzt werde ich wahrscheinlich dann der Einzige sein, der sich da äh jederzeit äh Eiswürfel und so äh,
alles dank verbrannter Dinosaurierfürze so. Man will nicht meinen, wofür die gut sind. Ich hätte auch gar nicht gedacht, dass man ähm mit Gas kalt machen kann.
Das macht jeder Wohnwagen.
Brennen von Gas. Genau, machen die, habe ich aber auch immer gedacht, geht nicht. Also,
geht kann ja eigentlich gar nicht gehen, aber geht, geht, habe ich hier stehen. Jetzt muss ich nur noch so eine Gas, so eine Gasflasche kaufen, ich bin mal gespannt, welche Lampen beim beim Verfassungsschutz angehen, wenn ich heute im Baumarkt,
Propangas kaufe.
Weil.
Häufung von Gas und Käufen im Umfeld von Berlin. Oha.
Ich bin ja,
Ich bin in der Regel ja im äh im Ausland beruflich tätig und da äh gibt's dann selten äh irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit darauf, äh in welchem Umfeld ich mich in Deutschland bewege und so, ne,
und ähm ich war jetzt letztens Mal in in Deutschland äh bei einem Kunden,
und äh da kam dann so ein Mitarbeiter und meinte so, ey, warte mal, Linus Nahmann, bist du der Linus Normann? Dich haben die hier reingelassen?
Fand ich auch sehr schön. Fand ich auch sehr schön. Ja. Genau, äh deswegen jetzt äh propagiert.
Zwei Identitäten brauchen wir mindestens, um irgendwie durchzuhalten.
Lieber Verfassungsschutz, ich verkaufe, ich kaufe die Propagassflasche wirklich nur äh fürs Camp zum zum Kühlen.
Klar.
Kümmert euch mal wieder um die Nazis, bitte.
So, endlich mal, überhaupt mal.
Überhaupt mal genau darauf zu schreddern und kümmert euch um die Nazis. Okay.
Äh
Wird Tim.
Eher äh ja, ja.
Du hast einen Fehler gemacht in der letzten Sendung. Hast du einen Fehler gemacht?
Ähm ja ja, man macht ja äh immer ähm Fehler. Also,
Vielleicht erstmal ich habe ja so ein bisschen ähm wir haben ja so ein bisschen gegen Flash äh gebasht, da gibt's ja dann durchaus auch noch Leute, die der Meinung sind, das wäre ja doch noch ein ganz,
das habe ich ja in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht bezweifelt. Kann sehr wohl ein brauchbares Tool sein für manche Leute, aber es ist halt einfach für.
Hacking Team zum Beispiel.
Äh ja, ne, sagen wir mal so, einfach als das für als dass es mal entstanden ist, so als Animations- und Prototyping äh Tool und keine Ahnung, wenn man so stent alone und irgendwelche Präsentationen hat, alles wunderbar. Nur halt so als äh Universalbeine, wie in allen Browsern in der selben Form, in allen
äh äh Maschinen auf dieser Welt ist es halt dann,
ein ein leichtes Ziel und dafür einfach nicht äh gehärtet genug. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall habe ich ja den ähm,
deutschen News-Seiten vor allem vorgeworfen, äh immer noch zu sehr die Leute in Richtung Flash zu drängen, ohne Not, unter anderem Spiegel Online. Und wie es nun mal der Zufall so wollte,
hat wohl ausgerechnet Spiele online tatsächlich das vor einem Monat abgestellt, sprich das gilt in der
in dem Sinne, wie ich's gesagt habe, nicht mehr, gilt aber sehr wohl für,
Spiegel TV und ich habe dann auch nochmal ein bisschen rumgeschaut, wie's aussieht und es sah gar nicht mehr so schlimm aus, aber Tage, Spiegel und N24 und solche äh Web,
bestehen dann doch ähm doch noch sehr auf äh Flash-Playern, ohne dass man da jetzt genau erkennen könnte, warum eigentlich.
Na ja, das wollte ich nur nochmal äh gesagt haben, um hier nicht ähm mit falschen Aussagen geladen zu sein.
Und dann hatten wir, ja dann hatten wir schönes dann hatten wir schönes Feedback zu deinen Einlassungen, zu Wahlcomputern.
Ja, das war ja ähm absehbar. Das hatte ich ja schon fast angekündigt, dass das stattfindet. Es ist ja auch in Ordnung. Ja, also
ich will da jetzt auch nicht so sehr in die äh Tiefe gehen, weil das führt dann auch wirklich vom Höschen aufs Stöckchen, aber,
wo man, also wir hatten ja in der letzten vorletzten Sendung, hatten wir ja sozusagen die grundsätzlich,
äh der Problematik von Wählen mit Computern äh thematisiert. Und ähm unter anderem habe ich halt ähm,
Einfache,
Wahlsystem in Deutschland mit Papier und Stift und Kabine äh gelobt. Da kam dann unter anderem der Hinweis, dass es ja in einigen Gemeinden mittlerweile der Fall ist und teilweise eben auch schon auf Länderebene, nämlich in Hamburg. Das ist ja dort dieses
verhältnismäßig neue System des Passagieren und kumulierens gibt. Das ist so ein ja äh auch schon etwas schwer zu erklärendes
ähm sondern schwer zu erklärende Erweiterung des Wahlsystems
wo man halt auch noch von Listen einzelne Teilnehmer streichen oder hinzuschreiben kann, sprich mehr so eine,
personenorientierte Wahl selber durchführen können, wenn man instant will. Das verkompliziert die äh Auszählung erheblich.
Dass die Aussage, dass das ja eigentlich ganz schnell geht, so natürlich dann auch äh nicht mehr stimmt. Und ja, die Frage ist nur.
Also wenn man sich halt so ein kompliziertes Wahlsystem zulegt
finde ich, dann muss man auch mit den Konsequenzen leben und dann einfach gleich zu schreien, na ja, jetzt ist es aber unser eigenes Wahlsystem zu kompliziert, jetzt brauchen wir Computer, damit das überhaupt noch funktioniert
Das führt dann halt genau in in dieses Dilemma, dass man sich am Ende eben von Systemen,
abhängig macht, die eben dann einfach keiner mehr versteht. Und das war dann auch noch mal so ein bisschen äh Debatte in den ähm,
in den Kommentaren ähm gab's dann so die typischen Nerdhinweise mit ja man selbstverständlich könnte man am Computer ja bei der Arbeit zu sehen, es gäbe ja so Sachen wie JTEC, also diese Debuting äh Schnittstellen an an Prozessoren und so,
da kriegt man dann schon ein bisschen das schwere Atmen, weil genau das ist halt so ein bisschen auch die,
Problematik, dass man's manchmal auch einfach nicht vermittelt bekommt. Nein, selbst wenn da eine Schnittstelle an so einem Computer dran ist, kann man dem nicht bei der Arbeit zuschauen. Also erstmal schon gar nicht in Echtzeit und zweitens,
auch so eine weitere Schnittstelle macht die Sache im besten Fall nur noch komplizierter, garantiert aber überhaupt nicht, dass das, was nach außen abgebildet wird, auch tatsächlich das ist, was innen stattfindet und, und, und, und das ist halt einfach das Grundproblem.
Ist auch so ein bisschen unpraktikabel, ne? Also ich meine ähm wenn ja jetzt jeder mit JTEC dran geht und äh guckt, ob seine Stimme da abgegeben wird, das ist
äh ein bisschen unpraktikabel. Es gab ja dann auch noch einen sehr schönen
Da hat jemand das, der hat, glaube ich, seine Diplom oder Studienarbeit oder so zu dem Thema geschrieben, wie man eben also mit,
Blindensignaturen und hasse alles nicht gesehen. Ein Kryptographische Trust Chain, die alles ähm,
abbildet mit der Wahl, unter anderem sogar eben auch die Option, dass man,
im Nachhinein verifizieren kann, dass die eigene Stimme auch tatsächlich gezählt wurde, also ein ein wunderbares Wahlverfahren, so erfüllt alle Anforderungen und etwas mehr. Ähm,
Aber äh ist, glaube ich, so in der, in der Realität unserer Gesellschaft im Moment in der Form nicht abzubilden. Ja, also als es nicht praktikabel ähm.
Und und geht auch davon aus, dass jeder das das äh versteht, was er da tut und dass die Leute in der Lage sind, da Schlüssel äh also wenn ich mir schon anschaue, welche Probleme ich beim Aufsetzen von GPG habe, dann weiß ich, dass das irgendwie alles äh dummt ist.
Wenn du dir anschaust, was die Leute für Probleme beim Machen eines einzelnen Kreuzes haben, ja, wenn du dir mal die Wahlergebnisse anschaust, ja?
Ja
Das ist schon kompliziert genug, ja.
Die wählen ja heute schon nicht das Richtige. Wie soll das denn erst noch werden? Nee, aber bei allem Humor, man muss sich einfach mal klarmachen, es gibt für eine für eine wohlinformierte und wohlorganisierte Diktatur.
Einfach keine einfachere Methode an der Macht zu bleiben, als Computer einzuführen. Das das muss man einfach mal so festlegen. Also in dem Moment, wo man einfach eine digitale Wahl hat,
Das ist leider in einigen Ländern schon so. Ähm,
Wenn da die Mächtigen nicht wiedergewählt werden, dann sind sie einfach äh aus irgendwelchen nicht mehr nachvollziehbaren ähm Gründen, entweder nicht ausreichend korrupt,
Noch nicht. Oder nicht ausreichend technisch informiert. Aber das ist einfach so einfach äh eine Wahl mit Computern zu bescheißen, insbesondere in der Form, wie sie heute in der Regel durchgeführt werden,
Ähm,
dass dass ich mich da über jeden Regierungswechsel nur wundern kann. Das wird aber dann auch nicht so lange so bleiben, ja, weil das das Wissen setzt sich langsam durch
und äh schön, wenn's hier so ein paar
Sonntagspolitiker gibt, die tatsächlich noch davon träumen, man könnte damit die Wahlbeteiligung steigern und das wäre doch alles nur für Wirtschaftsförderung und die Effizienz und überhaupt und man müsse ja modern sein, dann sage ich nur, Leute, sucht euch einen anderen Job,
leider irgendwie das Thema komplett verfehlt und müsst irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, was anderes machen, aber nicht, nicht bitte an der Stelle wirken.
Naja, Gott sei Dank kümmern sich ja die Politiker um andere Sachen. Zum Beispiel mischen sie sich ein, wenn.
Ja, das ist eigentlich äh das war jetzt so ein.
Wenn mal einer was tut.
Ein äh hätte ich eine Zusammenfassung so von von Andre, die ihr da veröffentlicht habt aus,
schon durchaus eigentlich ähm,
in in den Einzelstücken bekannten Informationen. Er hat aber, äh, wir kennen ja seine äh also der Andre, wenn er nicht gerade Artikel schreibt oder recherchiert,
ähm den Rest der Zeit füllt er ja dann auf durch das äh Stellen von Anfragen nach Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
IFG-Anfragen, dass ja auch, ihr gehört jetzt quasi zu seiner Recherchetätigkeit, aber das kann man da, glaube ich, im im Rahmen seiner Tätigkeit schon als eigenen Blog machen,
hat er ja auch, er betreibt ja quasi einen eigenen eine eigene Kategorie,
IFG Ablehnung des Tages. Das heißt, ihr schreibt so viele IFG-Anfragen, dass er quasi jeden Tag eine Ablehnung kriegt. Und ähm ey, hat sich jetzt eine,
Eine Frageliste der Bundesnetzagentur an äh Internet Provider,
geben lassen. So, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen ausholen. Das Ganze geht zurück bis in bis in wie in den Sommer zweitausenddreizehn. Da ging's also los mit ähm.
Mit diesem Snowden-Enthüllungen und da wurde halt relativ schnell klar, wenn da so eine Massenüberwachung im Internet stattfindet, wer sind denn dann so die Firmen, die den,
die dabei behilflich sein, behilflich sein müssen. Also wer sind die die großen ne? Da hatten wir auch schon öfter mal darüber gesprochen und die Namen, die da vielen äh insbesondere vielen.
Die auch in Deutschland tätig sind, waren Verizon,
Vodafone Level drei, Interout und ViaT. Alles große äh Internet äh Unternehmen und so, ne? Und jetzt äh hatte dann der,
Rechercheverband aus Süddeutsche und so,
ähm so gesagt, okay, da gab's ja so einen Artikel. Wer sind denn die Firmen, die oder die Unternehmen, die da helfen oder äh gezwungen sind, zu helfen bei diesen Überwachungen,
Und dieser äh und haben da eben diese Namen genannt. Und dieser Artikel hat also sehr viel Interesse im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium äh,
geweckt, wo zu dem Zeitpunkt, der ähm Herr Rösler noch tätig war von der FDP. Und der sagte also sofort, ähm ähm,
Also sein, sein Referat sicher,
äh es gibt also quasi ein Referat äh in den Wirtschaftsministerium, der Rüssel hat dann gesagt, okay, wir wollen jetzt ähm die B Netz A, die Bundesnetzagentur mit der Prüfung beauftragen, ob,
inwiefern Datenschutz und Fernmeldegeheimnis in Deutschland gewahrt werden durch die Unternehmen, die da als äh und Internetanbieter tätig sind.
Und das ging also relativ flott, dass er diesen Auftrag äh,
DRB Netz A gegeben hat, noch am nächsten Tag, also einen Tag nach dem Artikel, sagt der sofort, ey, hier prüfen wir ihn jetzt an, bin jetzt A hat noch in der selben Woche über ein Dutzend Firmen zu einem Erörterungstermin nach Bonn bestellt.
Und die Unternehmen haben den als eine Art Vorladung verstanden. Wir haben auch darüber bei äh Logbuch Netzpolitik damals berichtet, wenn ich mich jetzt,
korrekt entsinnen.
Haben wir, ja. Mhm.
Und und einen Tag vor diesem Treffen verschickt die Bundesnetzagentur einen Katalog,
zweiundzwanzig Fragen, wo sie sagten, hier übrigens zu diesen Themen, zu diesen Fragen wollen wir Auskunft von euch haben. Und der Landefeld, Klaus Landefeld, ähm,
Heißt der Klaus, Landefeld heißt auf jeden Fall. Ähm vor heiß Klaus, oder? Bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Klaus Landefeld vom.
Ja, ne, mit C.
Hm, der Klaus mit.
Mit K, jetzt hatte ich es richtig und.
Aber das ist Dezix mit C.
WC. So kann man sich das merken, ne. Ähm der erzählt hier auch schon im,
im äh im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, dass die Bundesnetzagentur einen Anruf aus dem Bundeskanzleramt bekommen hatte,
Bestimmte dieser äh zweiundzwanzig Fragen, nämlich die Fragen fünfzehn bis neunzehn. Äh nicht zu beantworten sind.
Und die Iris Hänseler Unger, die Vizepräsidentin der Bundesnetzagentur, äh hatte ähm.
Hat eben bei diesem Treffen quasi auch gesagt, ja,
bei der Einführung so ja die Fragen fünfzehn bis neunzehn auf die brauchen sie nicht einzugehen wissen wir Bescheid ja? Und die fragen fünfzehn bis neunzehn lauten,
Frage fünfzehn. Betreibt ihr Unternehmen Überwachungseinrichtungen nach dem Paragrafen sechsundzwanzig bis neunundzwanzig TKÜV zur Umsetzung sogenannter strategischer Beschränkungen nach dem Paragraph fünf äh und acht,
des GC-Gesetzes,
Fragesichts, wenn derartige Anlagen betrieben werden, werden hierfür auch die Regelungen zur Protokollierung der Nutzungen dieser Einrichtung sowie der sowie der Kontrolle dieser Protokollierung eingehalten.
Frage siebzehn. Gab es oder gibt es besondere Vorkommnisse, die im Rahmen der Protokollprüfung oder sonstiger Prüfungen der Überwachungseinrichtungen aufgefallen sind, die über die vereinzelte Fehlbedienung hinausgehen,
geht, von hinausgehen müsste es eigentlich heißen. Frage achtzehn, wird die Vorgabe zum beschränkten Zugang zu diesen Systemen eingehalten?
Ja? Also genau, was ist mit euren äh TKIV? Äh,
und den Überwachungs äh Einrichtung, die ihr habt für das äh äh für die für die äh für die eigentlich strafrechtliche äh ähm Strafverfolgungsgeschichten,
Ähm was ist mit denen? Wer hat da Zugriff drauf und wird darauf geachtet, dass es alles ähm,
ordentlich abläuft. TKÜV ist die Verordnung über die technische und organisatorische Umsetzung von Maßnahmen zu Überwachung, der Telekommunikation.
Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung.
Frage neunzehn, kannst du im Prinzip auch noch mit reinnehmen.
Grade nicht vorgelesen.
Neunzehn hast du vergessen.
Oh, guck mal, da war ich war mein Hirn in meinem Mund voraus. Ähm Frage neunzehn, werden darüber hinaus Systeme unterhalten, die eine Erstellung einer Kopie der Telekommunikation ermöglichen und wenn ja, wie wird deren Einsatz kontrolliert?
Genau, also relativ konkrete Fragen nach so aus damaliger Sicht so nach dem, was geht denn da bei euch überhaupt
weil wir erinnern uns, in der Zeit war ja, sagen wir mal, auch überhaupt noch
die Nachricht, dass grundsätzlich Abhörvorrichtungen bei Telekommunikations äh Unternehmen vorliegen
wie soll ich sagen, also nicht unvermutet, aber noch nicht allgemein äh allgemeines Wissen.
Na ja, also sie liegen vor, das ist klar. Da dazu sind sie auch nach dem nach den entsprechenden Gesetzen verpflichtet und nach dieser TKÜV-Verordnung. Aber entscheidend ist
ähm
enge Grenzen, ne? Muss Zugriff, muss protokolliert werden, Einschränkungen und so weiter. Ja und hier wird im Prinzip der der Frage nachgegangen,
missbrauchen Geheimdienste, die Abhöreinrichtungen, die existieren zum Zwecke der Strafverfolgung,
und ähm ich hatte ja, glaube ich, auch schon ausführlich dargelegt, dass diese äh TKÜ Einrichtungen,
derart gestaltet sind, dass die Provider selber nicht erkennen können, wer und was gerade abgehört wird. Das Beispiel, was sich da äh auch immer genannt habe, war, es wäre ja blöd, wenn bei der Telekom,
oder bei, ne? Bei diesen jeweiligen Unternehmen eine einigermaßen,
mittelprächtig bezahlte Arbeitskraft. Ähm Wissen darüber erlangt, an wem Deutsche,
Verfolgungsbehörden gerade Interessen haben, Interesse haben, denn diese Person könnte sehr, sehr gute Nebeneinkünfte damit machen, ähm,
die Zielperson zu warnen. Ja, also es gibt einen guten Grund dafür, ähm zu sagen, okay, der Zugang zu diesen Systemen,
und die das Wissen, wer wen überwacht soll.
In der Hand der Strafverfolgungsbehörden selber sein. Deswegen laufen da einfach äh Mirror äh gespiegelte Porz rein, gespiegelte Kabel rein, wo einfach einmal alle Kommunikation drin ist und die Strafverfolgungsbehörde
sucht sich das aus. Und die naheliegende Vermutung ist natürlich zu sagen, ah,
Das heißt, die unterliegen keiner Kontrolle. Das heißt, da steckt einfach der Geheimdienst direkt mit dran. Und äh macht dann noch, was er für, was er an, an der entsprechenden Stelle für richtig hält.
Genau dieser Frage wird danach gegangen und.
Der Skandal an dieser Stelle ist eben, dass da eine wunderschöne Initiative auf Betreiben des äh des,
Wirtschaftsministeriums stattgefunden hat. Die Bundesnetzagentur sehr gute und berechtigte Fragen gestellt hat und dann eine klare,
Anweisung aus dem Bundeskanzleramt kam, darüber keine Auskunft geben. Und wie an den Fragen deutlich wird, das waren genau die kritischen Fragen.
Und genau deshalb,
geht ja jetzt genau die wurden eben nicht gestellt beziehungsweise nicht beantwortet bei den Fragen bei diesen zweiundzwanzig Fragen Minus fünf war es also so, dass man gesagt hat.
Ähm die müsst ihr bei diesem Gespräch erörtern und dann auch nochmal schriftlich. Ja, im Anschluss. Und ähm,
weil diese vier, weil diese fünf gestrichen wurden, sagte Pofalla dann eben auch am zwölften August zweitausenddreizehn
auch die in Deutschland relevanten Internetknotenpunktbetreiber und Verbindungsnetzbetreiber haben gegenüber der Bundesnetzagentur am vergangenen Freitag erneut,
dass sie die Vorgaben des Telekommunikationsgesetzes in Deutschland einhalten. Dies umfasst insbesondere auch die Vorschriften zum Schutz der Daten unserer Bürgerinnen und Bürger. Das Fernmeldegeheimnis,
dementsprechend von den Unternehmen gewahrt,
So und Pofalla ist ja wohl mal ähm zu dem Zeitpunkt äh Kanzleramtsminister gewesen.
Genau und damit zuständig äh für die Geheimdienste.
Und damit zuständig für das Nichtstellen dieser Fragen. So, also er,
Aus dessen Haus kam quasi so, wenn ihr die fünf Fragen nicht stellt, dann überstehend überstehen die Unternehmen und wir, diese Befragung.
So, weiter geht's im Jahresbericht der der Bundesnetzagentur findet diese Befragung keinerlei Erwähnung.
Keinerlei Erwähnungen,
Städten, was hat die Bundesnetzagentur ganze Jahr gemacht? Ha, hier, hier, hier, ja, ne, irgendwie, das, das findet keine Erwähnung. Und sie haben auch zu dieser Befragung keinerlei Pressemitteilungen rausgegeben. Es gibt nur so einen Sprechzettel.
Ähm für äh das Sprechzettel heißt, wenn mal einer fragt, gibt's den folgende Antwort, wo dann sowas drinsteht, ja hier alles super, ne, tadellos, hier äh keine Frage, auf deutschen äh Boden wird deutsches Recht gewahrt, ne?
Ah, richtig.
Die Unternehmen bekräftigten sich ausschließlich an den Deutschland geltenden Gesetze zu halten. Sie gewähren ausländischen Diensten keinen Zugriff auf Telekommunikationsdaten. Die Unternehmen weisen die in der Presse erhobenen Vorwürfe entschieden, zurück die so,
Alter. Der Pofalla ist wirklich ein ein ähm ein schadhaftes Element.
Naja, deswegen geht er jetzt auch zur Bahn.
Weißt du, wofür der der Veranstalter dich sein wird? Unter anderem.
Unter anderem für.
Datenschutz, Datenschutz.
Hier kann man echt nur noch drüber lachen.
Oh Gott.
Noch zwei andere Wörter. Ich muss das mal kurz suchen, ja. So.
Oh. Wow, super.
Kein Scheiß. Äh.
Der hat noch zwei andere Themenbereiche. Datenschutz, Recht und Regeltreue.
Mhm. Kriege Treue. Aha.
Regeltreue, Datenschutzrecht und Regeltreue. Alter, das kann echt nicht wahr sein. Das kann echt nicht wahr sein.
Der Bock zum Gärt.
Also ich meine, jemand.
Jemand, der wirklich jede Regel, die es für ihn jemals gab, gibt, gebrochen hat, ja? Der jedes Recht, was jeweils noch für ihn galt, gebrochen hat und der Datenschutz irgendwie,
also ja, super, also Deutsche Bahn, wunderbar, mach mal schön weiter so ähm ja.
In Deutschland. Gut, haben wir alles dazu gesagt, aber eigentlich, oder?
Also Kanzleramt äh hat sich aktiv eingemischt und eine äh frühzeitig von dem ahnungslosen Herrn Rößler äh eingeleitete Untersuchungen torpediert, so dass am Ende nicht viel bei rausgekommen ist. Schön.
Sie haben's noch nicht mal torpediert, sie haben es wirklich, das kann man als eine aktive Manipulation einfach bezeichnen. Weil der Presse sagst du, ja, wir haben den ja.
Wir haben den ja, äh wir haben den ja siebzehn Fragen gestellt.
Nur halt nicht alle, die wir ursprünglich vorhatten, so Details,
Na ja, da können wir ja froh sein, dass das äh im NSA äh Untersuchungsausschuss alles äh klar geregelt ist und dass da äh keine Zweifel an der ordnungsgemäßen Durchführung des Prozesses bestehen
Richtig.
Ja klar, natürlich, also NSA Untersuchungsausschuss äh Sitzung, wir machen jetzt Sitzungspause, aber der gute Herr,
graulich ähm der Sonderermittler äh und Selektorenprüfer, der nimmt jetzt seine Arbeit auf,
bezieht dazu seinen sein Büro in der BND Zentrale.
Was? Echt? Wow. Was?
Ja, der wird das in der BND-Zentrale machen.
Das ähm okay.
Das ist super, weil wenn man ja auch, ne, überprüfen soll, was die BND so richtig gemacht hat, dann muss man, da muss man einfach am Ort des Geschehens sein, da muss man einfach direkt am Lagerfeuer sich die Hände wärmen.
So, der wird halt äh ähm,
Also es ist der äh ehemalige Bundesverwaltungsverwaltungsrichter, der eben von der Koalition äh auserkoren wurde als Sonderermittler in Sachen äh Selektoren. Das heißt, der wird jetzt diese Selektorenlisten beim BND einsehen,
ja? Und wird dann äh über die Details seiner Prüfung nicht berichten dürfen. Dem NSA-Untersuchungs.
Wir hatten da ja schon drüber berichtet, aber vielleicht sollten wir nicht immer davon ausgehen, dass immer schon alle irgendwie was äh hinkommen. Vielleicht nochmal kurz eine so. Also es gab sozusagen eine grundsätzliche Auseinandersetzung dadrüber, ähm dass die
ähm vor allem die Opposition, Untersuchungsausschuss doch gerne mal Einblick hätte in diese Selektoren, um die es die ganze Zeit geht, um das besser verstehen zu können, weil das ja ein Untersuchungsausschuss ist und dann hat halt das Kanzleramt gesagt, so mhm na ja, äh das ist aber alles geheim,
und äh wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie Geheimnisse äh da in so Untersuchungsausschüsse äh äh reintragen? Am Ende könnt ihr uns hier ähm,
die Legislative dann ähm auch noch kontrollieren. Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Und der Kompromiss war äh oder das Kompromissangebot war ein äh Sonderermittler einzusetzen, dem das sozusagen alles dargelegt
der das dann vorgekaut äh weiterreichen kann. Da war dann die Opposition nicht ganz so von
begeistert von diesem Prozess, aber da wir ja so wunderbare Mehrheitsverhältnisse haben, hat sich das dann eben entsprechend
durchgesetzt und ja, jetzt ist er halt da, Herr Graulich und äh will sich das alles mal anschauen, was jetzt dann mit diesen Selektoren eigentlich auf sich hat und wird dann in irgendeiner Form irgendwie berichten,
heißt es.
Allerdings halt ohne Details, ne, sehr wird dann also ich meine, der wird wahrscheinlich auf äh also ich würde mir,
wünschen, dass er dann wenigstens, ne, also auf die, dass man ihm so eine Frage stellen kann, wie wurde da Wirtschaftsspionage äh betrieben und geduldet, dass er dann auf sowas eine Antwort geben kann, aber äh ne.
Ist nicht von auszugehen, ja.
Ja Vicky, liegt's, die schaffen ja Klarheit derzeit.
Genau, denn Vicky Leaks veröffentlicht ja jetzt äh einfach sportlich immer wieder äh kleine Selektoren äh Sammlungen äh auf äh WikiLeaks dot org,
äh wo dann die letzten vier Zeichen geixt sind und wo sie dann sagen, ja hier übrigens, ne, Steinmeier haben sie auch überwacht und äh dann veröffentlichen sie ja auch immer Beispiel Kommunikäs, ja? Äh äh,
also quasi Beispiel Abhörprotokolle, ja? Und hier was sie jetzt zu Steinmeier haben, haben sie jetzt irgendwie wieder, ich glaube so um die zwanzig Selektoren, wo dann eben seine verschiedenen,
Telefonnummern zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten ähm mit drin sind,
Tier aller möglichen Mitarbeiter und so, ja? Und dann haben sie halt wieder so einen einen veröffentlicht, ähm wo drin beschrieben wird, das sind also so Summerries, ja?
Der hat also einen Analyst, äh das Gespräch dann abgehört oder mehrere und schreibt dann so seinen Bericht. Und da schreibt er so, ja,
Nachdem der äh nachdem der Steinmeier sich also mit Kondo Lisa Rice getroffen hatte, der damaligen.
War die Außen-und nee Außen äh hier Kriegsministerin war die, oder?
Außenministerin war sie. Bitte. Außenministerin.
Doch Außenminister.
Michael, ja.
Ja, die hat gewechselt. Die hatte zwei die hatte zwei Dinger. Ich weiß nicht, was sie zu oder täuscht mich da jetzt. Kurz schauen.
Ich schlage das mal kurz nach. Außenministerin von zweitausendfünf bis zweitausendneun war sie. Vorher war sie Sicherheitsberaterin.
Genau das, das war das, was ich dachte, aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt muss sie dann äh jetzt muss ich auf das Datum schauen, welches Amt sie zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte. So einfach wollen wir's euch ja nicht machen hier, äh.
Fehler bei uns zu finden. Wiki Leaks.
In welchem Jahr redest du jetzt genau?
Ich muss das Jahr jetzt nochmal raus.
Also von welchem Ereignis redest du jetzt genau?
Dass der, da hat der Steinmeier sich mit getroffen und da ging es um die CIA äh Entführungsflüge, die ja so in äh Deutschland und in Europa stattfinden, ja?
So
Ah, zweitausendfünf, ja, die Intersep Dates from just after official visit to the United States on twenty nine November two thousand five. Da war sie also dann äh genau, da war sie Außenministerin, ja.
Grade geworden.
Grade gewonnen und er hat sich dann nämlich Steinmeier mit ihr äh unterhalten und in dem Interset steht dann nachher drin erschien sehr erleichtert zu sein,
dass er keine definitive Antwort von der Außenministerin bekommen hat, äh bezüglich der Medienberichte, dass CIA-Flüge,
durch Deutschland gingen auf dem Weg zu den geheimen Gefängnissen in Osteuropa, wo dann ähm,
also Folter äh stattfand, stattfinde. Da ging's also um die ganze Steinmeier-Affäre, äh die CIA-Folterflüge hieß das dann glaube ich auch, äh korrekt in den äh,
in den ähm in den Medien, ne
Und da sagt er, da hat er also gesagt, so gut, dass die mir da jetzt keinen definitives Wissen gegeben haben. So kann ich mein äh Gewissen weiterhin als rein bezeichnen, dass Deutschland äh entweder nicht davon weiß oder
ähm nicht daran beteiligt ist an den äh Folter verhören, die da stattfinden. Ja und das ist also hier,
als Beispiel rausgegeben. Steinmeier hätte außerdem gesagt, dass er.
Dass die äh das Washington große Hoffnung in die neue Regierung äh von Deutschland hätte.
Und dass er jetzt nach Bereichen suchen würde, wo man die bilaterale Kooperation stärken könnte.
Zum Beispiel im Kaukasus. Ja.
Ja, genau, also Wiki Leaks äh veröffentlicht schön weiter. Ähm und äh,
Was ich ja sehr schön finde, ist, dass sie halt einerseits sagen, guck mal hier, ähm,
die hören euch ab, hier sind die Selektoren und übrigens, das was ihr euch abhören, ist übrigens auch nochmal scheiße für euch, das veröffentlichen wir dann auch mal direkt mit, weil ähm Steinmeier ähm natürlich schon seit ja, jetzt inzwischen,
zehn Jahren im Kreuzfeuer steht wegen seiner ähm
Beteiligung äh und seinem Mitwissen über so Entführungen wie die von äh Murat, ja. Da gibt's also äh wunderschöne äh Beispiele,
wie der Steinmeier da äh Grundrechte äh gewürdigt hat, wann immer es darum ging, mit den USA zu kooperieren,
gleichzeitig hier so 'n so 'n Pontius Pilatus Ding macht und sagt, ja gut, dass die mir nichts gesagt haben, dann kann ich jetzt ruhigen Gewissens, äh, bin ich, bin ich, äh, zumindest nicht, ähm,
nachweislich darüber im Bilde, was da genau stattfindet und kann meine Hände weiterhin in in Unschuld waschen. So, dann hat ähm.
Assange, ein sehr beachtetes Interview dem äh Nachrichtenmagazin der Spiegel gegeben.
Indem er dann sagte so, ja Wiki Leaks äh steht wie eh und je stark im Saft. Wir müssen Namen natürlich große Aufgaben für unsere ganzen gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzungen und äh für unsere Anwälte äh interessante Zahlen hat er da
genannt, zum Beispiel das Wikileaks in seiner Vereinsgeschichte um die einhundertfünfzig verschiedene Anwälte äh weltweit irgendwie im Einsatz hatte
wahrscheinlich nicht alle gleichzeitig, ne? Aber ähm das ist schon auch eine straffe Zahl und äh eine Zahl, die ich da auch sehr interessant fand, war, dass er daraufhin, wie es das Schweden,
Seit dem Beginn seiner äh seines äh Konfliktes mit den äh schwedischen, mit der schwedischen Staatsanwältin ähm,
aufgrund der äh anhaltenden Beschuldigung wegen äh sexueller Belästigung Schrägstrich Vergewaltigung,
dass seitdem vierzig Mal äh schwedische ähm Untersuchungs äh.
Untersuchungsbefragungen in einem anderen Land, beziehungsweise sogar in den UK allein stattgefunden haben. Das muss ich nochmal kurz gucken.
Äh auch da habe ich jetzt natürlich genau den Link nicht, aber das sagt er
sagte er in diesem Interview, wovon es auch eine Abschrift gibt, jetzt habe ich ich muss mal besser, besser das pflegen
und dann sagt er, ja, übrigens, wir haben ja jetzt hier viele Selektoren und so und ich habe ja auch äh zur Kenntnis genommen, dass das schon wieder gesagt wird, ja, diese, bei den Selektoren wären ja die letzten vier Zahlen geixt und deswegen,
die ihr jetzt nicht als Beweis oder so, ne? Was ja schon sehr äh sehr äh,
äh lächerliches äh Rumlavieren, wie da ist. Und da hat er gesagt, er wäre also sehr gerne bereit als äh Zeuge vor dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss aufzutreten,
und wer also auch sehr gerne bereit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss äh diese selektorenlisten ungeschwärzt äh zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Weil hat er ja.
War hier so, könnt ihr haben. Ähm,
Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr schön. Ähm ich muss sagen, ich finde die Rolle, die Wiki Leaks da jetzt spielt in letzter Zeit wieder ähm durchaus begrüßenswert. Es war ähm.
Finde ich sehr lange Zeit ähm,
Ein bisschen düster und lächerlich geworden, äh um um die Person Julian Assange ähm als dann die Snowden Sachen losging, äh fand ich dann auch so dieses,
reindrängeln von oder da habe ich das Verhalten von WikiLeaks auch erst so als ein reindrängeln empfunden. Dann diese äh,
wiederholte ähm Heldenverehrung von von Sarah Harrison an bei jeder Gelegenheit ähm das stoßen wir alles irgendwie so ein bisschen,
als unsachlich und äh mythisch irgendwie auf, aber ähm diese Veröffentlichung, die Wiki Leaks jetzt gerade in letzter Zeit wieder tätigt, sind also sehr ähm,
sehr enorm gut aufgearbeitet,
sehr hilfreich, ja? Ähm sauber dokumentiert mit Erklärungen versehen. Ähm natürlich auch sehr gut ähm,
ausgewählt, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Auswahl jetzt von ihrer Quelle getroffen wurde oder von der, von dem Wiki Leaks,
oder Julian Assange, aber das das sitzt so die äh spielen jetzt wieder äh an vorderster Front in in dieser Debatte mit. Und ähm das ist sicherlich ähm.
Auf jeden Fall begrüßenswert. Ja, steht aber eben auf einem anderen Blatt als jetzt diese Posse, um äh die Anschuldung, die da ähm,
seit vielen Jahren jetzt eben äh unverändert im Raume stehen, wo äh kein Schritt gemacht wird in die Richtung, dass sich daran etwas ändert, ja.
Und ich denke, wenn da jetzt derartig viele Befragungen im Ausland stattgefunden haben, dann äh schwächelt auch sehr stark das Argument, äh dass die,
schwedische Staatsanwältin da nicht äh zu einer Befragung einreist äh und stärkt die Sorge von äh Julian Assange und seinen Anwälten, dass es sich hierbei äh entweder um eine äh,
Kampagne handelt oder eben um den Versuch, ihn irgendwie seiner habhaft zu werden äh zum Zwecke der Auslieferung an die USA.
Mhm. Ja. Also die Prüfung.
Andre hat natürlich noch eine IFG-Anfrage gemacht zu den Selektoren, ne? Klar.
Haben. Und äh die wurde aber abgelehnt,
weil äh ist auch sehr schön die die Begründung, wenn bekannt wird, welche Ziele die USA in Deutschland und Europa überwachen,
Würde das die vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit mit den USA beeinträchtigen?
Und das ist also die Begründung des Kanzleramtes, warum sie die Herausgabe der vierzigtausend aussortierten Speziele verweigert.
Darf eben nur der Graulich anschauen äh beim BND, ja und darf dann darüber nicht erzählen, ja.
Aber ich finde es sehr geil, ja? Wenn, wenn wir jetzt also lieber Herr Meister,
Wenn wir jetzt öffentlich machen, welche vierzigtausend Ziele die Amerikaner in Deutschland und in Europa mit Hilfe unserer eigenen Abhöreinrichtung überwacht haben,
dann beschädigt das leider unser Vertrauensverhältnis zu denen. Das können wir nicht machen, dann vertrauen die uns nicht mehr. Ganz,
Ich meine, das ist auch echt geil, irgendjemand sitzt ja auch da, muss dieses jetzt zu schreiben, ja? Und ich stelle mir halt entweder vor, entweder sitzt da so jemand, der sich irgendwie in Grund und Boden schämt, ja,
und irgendwie für jede Antwort, die ihr irgendwie schreiben muss, sich einen neuen Pass irgendwie ausstellen lässt und seine Identität wechselt, ja.
Schwitzend.
Oder da sitzt so jemand und lacht sich die ganze Zeit Schrott.
Das ist echt.
Oder da sitzt irgendwie einer mit mit, da sitzt so einer mit so einem grauen Anzug und so einem Stempel,
und schreibtet darunter und schüttelt den Kopf, warum der andere überhaupt so eine blöde Frage gestellt hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Fände ich äh ich wäre äh da würde ich gerne mal Maus spielen äh wie es da bei solchen Beantwortungen.
Ja, das ist so wie äh Herr Kohl irgendwie seiner Zeit mit seinen Spenderlisten, ne. Also, ne
das könnte ja auch nicht sagen, weil er hätte ja da sein Ehrenwort gegeben und das äh wäre halt einfach mal total äh wichtig, ne. Ich freue mich.
Gauner-Ehrenwort.
Ja, ich freue mich wie sie, ob sowas irgendwie vor Gericht generell Bestand hat. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie eine Bank überfalle und dann wäre ich da mit mir geschnappt und dann höre ich so zu meinen Hinternmännern äh befragt so, naja, das,
Natürlich schon sagen, aber das würde leider mein Vertrauensverhältnis zu meinen Komplizen,
äh leicht beeinträchtigen und äh ich weiß nicht, also das geht nicht.
Als würde das Vertrauensverhältnis zum Afia ähm stark beeinträchtigen, das geht nicht. Die,
Aber überhaupt von Vertrauen zu reden, ja. In einer solchen Situation ist einfach äh ist einfach nur erbärmlich, ja. Na ja.
Aus. Genau, so sieht's äh aus in diesem Lande und ähm wir schütteln auch weiterhin den Kopf,
Nicht wahr? Ja, das äh bleibt nicht aus.
So Linus, damit haben wir's eigentlich auch, ne? Ausnahmsweise mal eine eine kürzere Sendung, trotzdem eine Stunde lang.
Ja, muss ja auch mal sein. Wie fandest du übrigens letzte Sendung mit Andre?
Fand ich äh sehr nett, fand ich sehr äh,
sehr ähm wichtig auch mal so ein bisschen die ganzen Berichterstattungen äh auszuloten und so ein bisschen die Motivation zu hinterfragen, jetzt bei Andre und allen anderen, die da beteiligt sind
und äh auch wenn er sich so ein bisschen am Ende darum gedrückt hat, ne, wirklich Einschätzung herauszugeben, wohin es denn mit diesem ganzen Untersuchungsausschuss äh führt. War das, glaube ich,
so oder so eine sehr wertvolle Einblick. Hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Ja, danke.
Audio, was wir noch arbeiten.
Lob vom Meister. Ja, die ähm das ist äh ne, da äh.
Die Dinge nun mal so wie sie sind.
Der hatte auch alles. Der hätte.
Aber alles wird besser und alles wird gut und äh das Camp äh rückt näher
und ähm ja, wie schon erwähnt, wir werden dann halt äh live senden. Ihr seid hoffentlich alle dabei, wenn ihr euch noch kein Camp-Ticket gekauft habt, dann macht er das jetzt mal und sorgt mal dafür, dass er da äh auf den Acker kommt, weil das wird eine,
tolles Ereignis und das wollt ihr sicherlich nicht verpassen.
Übrigens, die fetten Jahre sind vorbei, ne, hier mit äh mit,
Wir haben jetzt festgestellt, ähm da der Tim ja hier in seinem Podcast überall für die für die äh Spartickets geworben hat, ja? Äh,
in der IT- und Hackerszene so auf einmal so eine plötzliche Armut ausgebrochen, sodass jetzt alle nur noch low budget Tickets gekauft haben. Ja, das geht so nicht mehr.
Hm, tschau.
Nee, also ich äh ich hatte den, ich habe jetzt, mir drängte sich jetzt so am am Ende bei den Verkaufszahlen der Eindruck
auf, dass unter Umständen einige Leute ihre Bedürftigkeit dann da ein bisschen überschätzt haben, äh weil jetzt so im Schnitt ja eigentlich bei den Campbesuchern äh man ja dann doch davon ausgehen kann, dass die ähm,
in ganz guten äh beruflichen Situationen sich befinden. Ne, das soll also für den Einzelfall,
oder für diejenigen bei denen der bei denen der Bedarf tatsächlich gegeben ist für genau für die haben wir diese Tickets und genau für die Leute haben wir auch,
keinerlei Überprüfung oder sonst was für diese Tickets, aber wenn das dann so so unglaublich viele Leute werden, dann ähm dann äh,
dann denkt man da, da heckt auch jemand, da heckt doch jemand an seinem äh,
Heckt ja jemand und äh deswegen müsst ihr jetzt alle äh das Business Platinum Ticket bitte kaufen für schmale äh siebenhundertzwanzig Euro.
Und ich glaube, es äh es äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hatten wir sogar irgendwie mal angekündigt, wann es keine Tickets mehr geben würde. Sollen wir mal gucken. Also jetzt wird's wirklich allerhöchste Eisenbahn,
äh da jetzt mal äh seine seine Tickets zu sichern.
Denn, ach so, weißt du, was wir gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das erwähnt haben, Tim, das ist ja mal fett. Ich äh ich darf ja jetzt endlich drüber reden, denn es ist ja gute Tradition bei den Camps, dass man ein sogenanntes Badge bekommt.
Ja? Und ähm bei dem bei dem letzten Camp gab's so eine schöne, so eine schöne Rakete,
raketenförmige Platine, die dann so verschiedene Sachen zum dranstecken hat und so und kann man Display draufmachen und dann hat das so ein äh Funk äh so ein so ein Mesh Netzwerk gemacht und äh alles ganz witzig und man konnte irgendwie seinen Namen drauf anzeigen und so
ein lustiges kleines Spielzeug, ein äh also so ein Prototyping Board, mit dem man so allen möglichen Kram machen konnte. Das war schon ganz nett.
Und dieses Jahr gibt es ein ähm kompatibles SDR, ja. Äh und das ist mal was richtig Fettes. Also das das,
glaube ich, dieses Jahr ist auf jeden Fall so das fetteste Batch, was es je irgendwo,
bei einer Hackerveranstaltung obendrauf gegeben hat, weil es ein Software eingebaut hat, mit dem man,
im Bereich von fünfzig Megaherz bis viertausend Megaherz,
senden und empfangen kann, ja? Und das ist also kompatibel mit der supergeilen Platine Heck AF äh mit dem supergeilen ja doch das Hacki ist eine Platine, die ähm,
also ein teil was zu relativ straffen Preisen verkauft wird und,
auch ziemlich geil ist. Und damit kann man also allerlei allerlei schicken Schabernack
äh treiben. Das dann irgendwie so äh an seinen Computer anschließen und eben,
Funksignale in allen möglichen Bereichen empfangen und äh sich dann mit Gno-Radio zusammensetzen und anfangen irgendwie, was weiß ich, mal sein,
Hausalarmsystem oder die äh Fernbedienbaren Steckdosen oder den Garagenöffner zuknacken und äh das wird also ein ein wunderbares Spielzeug. Ich
freu mich da unglaublich drauf und das wird richtig richtig.
Man könnte eigentlich sagen, dass, das ist das erste Batch, wo man obendrauf noch so ein eigenes Camp mit dazu kriegt. Dass er das erste fette SDR, wo man oben drauf noch ein kleines Camp mit dabei kriegt, um sich's abzuholen.
Richtig dicker Shit.
Genau, mehr dazu, wenn ihr da noch äh tiefer einsteigen wollt, äh letzte Friedshow von letzter Woche, da haben wir das nämlich schon ausführlich äh besprochen. Bei unserem Camp Preview. Ähm ja.
Wem das jetzt alles nichts gesagt hat, egal. Trotzdem äh kommen schlimmsten Fall kann man sich das an den Kamin hängen.
Wenn euch das nichts sagt, ne, gebt da einfach mir, ist kein Problem. Ich kann auf jeden Fall was anfangen.
Ich stelle dann bei mir am Zelt so eine Dose so eine Kiste hin, da könnt ihr das alles reinwerfen.
An used Radios.
Na toll. Linos, wir müssen jetzt hier Schluss machen. Äh wir sehen uns.
Ja, dann nee, nee, nee.
Nächste Woche nochmal, oder?
Ja, genau. Und die Woche vorm Camp äh gehe ich davon aus, dass wir beide dann schon äh uns mit mit Sonnencreme auf der Nase und im Nacken mit dem Spaten in der Hand auf dem Ziegeleipark befinden. Das wird dann also übernächste Woche eher keine Sendung geben.
Nächstes nächste Woche versuchen wir nochmal, aber ich muss ja an dieser Stelle jetzt nochmal wirklich,
einen besonderen Dank aussprechen an den Alexander, der weiß genau wieso, weißt du ganz genau,
Es gibt also einmal den den besonderen Dank mit Sternchen.
Und wer auch, ja, einen ganz besonderen Dank mit Sternchen bekommt,
Das weiß er auch und das ist er auch ein ein also ein ein Serientäter, das ist der Bernd auch an dieser Stelle nochmal ganz herzlichen Dank,
und ähm die immer wieder zitierte unbekannte Personen,
bekommt auch einen besonders herzlichen Dank an dieser Stelle.
Richtig was los hier. Gut, haben wir jetzt ausgedankt. Okay.
Denke ja. Danke.
Dann danke ich auch noch mal hier allen äh Zuhörern und sonstigen Unterstützern und äh richtig lieb haben wir euch dann, wenn ihr aufm Camp seid und äh da sehen wir uns dann.
Tschau, tschau.
Bis bald, tschüss.